we are at the diamond light source just
outside oxford in england we're here for
the next week or so to do an experiment
and we are standing in the synchrotron
right now you can see it all around
a synchrotron is a particle accelerator
where electrons are circulated around
in a roughly circular or pretty well
circular trajectory
very very very close to the speed of
light we are not so much interested
unlike particle physicists we're not so
much interested in the particles of
themselves what we are interested in for
our experiments is the fact that when
you take a charged particle like an
electron and circulate it very very
close to the speed of light or
accelerate it virtual speed of light
what it does is it gives off what's
called synchrotron radiation so this is
radiation that goes all the way from
infrared up to very very hard very very
high energy x-rays and we as condensed
matter physicists solid-state physicists
nano-scientists whatever you want to
call us
what we are most interested in is
harnessing that light
shining it onto a sample and learning
about what the atoms and molecules in
that sample are doing we walk around is
there's a sort of hissing noise
and the hissing noise comes from
nitrogen gas
now because of this very bright light
that we have it's very very focused but
it can get quite hot so we are standing
right above what is called beamline
i-09 what's a beam line well you have
the electrons circulating around how do
you get the light out well what happens
is you have
tubes funnels
through which the light travels and
those are as you can see
us going off into the distance you might
be able to see this in terms of just
coming off tangentially to the to the
ring we're on the surfaces and
interfaces line just here just down here
and we will be collecting that light
coming from those electrons and shining
it
onto our sample down in this
experimental hutch down here so to get
beam time
you have to like anything in science you
have to write a grant proposal you have
to get the time you have to get the
funding for the work and we wrote that
proposal quite some time ago almost a
year ago now so we were hugely excited
when we got the time and now we're
hugely excited to be here to actually be
able to exploit this synchrotron
radiation
so what we're looking at here is
obviously we need to have optics to get
this light down but this is optics these
are x-ray optics and we need to be able
to get those x-rays onto our sample to
focus them down the synchrotron is about
10 billion times brighter than the sun
so this is an immense engineering
challenge with very very clever people
doing this work um to to ensure that we
can get that those very bright x-rays
and get them onto our sample so that the
tube you can see i'm coming down here is
actually the tube that is carrying the
beam to our to our chamber it's all
ultra high vacuum so it's a pressure
comparable to that you get on the
surface of the moon the electrons are
not in that tube the electrons are
basically circulating away over there
what we at what is coming down this tube
is the light generated by those
electrons and that's going to come into
our or similarly ultra high vacuum
chamber we're going to have those x-rays
and they're going to impinge on our
sample and then we're going to find out
wonderful things about our particular
molecule
we're in the experimental hoter this is
where we actually do the experiments and
the light actually comes in through this
tube here and then we're going to chase
that through we've got some mirrors etc
some more optics some
various dips of diagnosis and then we're
coming all along all along
into our experimental chamber here it's
an ultra high vacuum chamber stainless
steel
uh pressure in here very very low again
comparable to the surface of the moon
and our sample sits in there so the beam
is coming into our chamber and it's
going to the beam is going to hit our
sample and it's going to eject electrons
out and we want to measure the energies
at which those electrons come out it's
actually something called the
photoelectric effect which um it wasn't
for a relativity that einstein won his
nobel prize it was actually for the
photoelectric effects something called
photoemission that's what we're doing
here one part it's just one part of what
we're doing here photons in electrons
out and every
material has its own signature in terms
of its photoemission spectrum so this is
our electron energy analyzer this
wonderful
hemispherical analyzer it's literally
called a hemispherical analyzer and the
way we measured the energies of the
electrons is that we have a couple of
spheres in here and we put a voltage
uh on those spheres and then what we do
is we play off the um centripetal um
force on the electrons against that that
voltage so we play off the centripetal
force against the electrostatic force
and only those electrons that have got
the right um kinetic energy the right
speed are actually going to make it
through and then we vary the voltages
and we can collect a spectrum that way
so that acts like a filter precisely
that's exactly what it does it's an
energy filter so it allows us to detect
how many electrons we've got at a
certain energy all these different arms
you can see
those are allowing us to move samples
around in vacuum without breaking the
vacuum and so we can use these arms to
move the sample around
what they're doing over here what sam's
doing at the moment is sorting out um
the the important aspect this experiment
let me tell you about the experiment
we're gonna do so this is the molecule
we're interested in it's a absolutely
fascinating molecule it's a c60 it's a
what's called a buckminster fullerene
inside we've got a single water molecule
and this is made we don't make this
we're not half clever enough we're
physicists we're not clever enough to do
this this is made by our colleagues in
southampton they do something called
molecular surgery they open up a hole in
the cage
they drop a water molecule in and then
they seal up the hole just with wet
chemistry it's phenomenal the water
molecule is trapped within a cage it's
encaged it's it's incarcerated within
within this molecule why is that
interesting well first of all you've got
a single water molecule not interacting
with any of the water molecules this is
not something you find very often nature
the c60 is about a nanometer across once
you can find molecules once you can find
atoms once you can find particles to
small spaces that's when you start to
see very interesting quantum effects
what we're really interested in is can
we exploit those effects when we take
this molecule and put it down onto a
surface
and the first question to ask is when
you put it down onto a surface and the
cage bonds to the surface does the
molecule
inside just the water molecule feel the
effect of the surface or is this just
like a faraday cage does it completely
screen it out so that the water molecule
doesn't see the surface there are a
number of different things we do but the
first is to exploit this photoelectric
effect this photoemission effect photons
come in
we excite electrons out of the oxygen
and we can look at the spectrum of those
electrons to work out what's happening
with the water molecule where do we get
those photons well we get them from the
beam line why do we need the beam line
and why is a synchrotron why don't we
just do this with an x-ray source back
in nottingham why don't we do it in a
lab the great thing about a synchrotron
is that you can tune the photon energy
across a very wide range in this case
from 100 electron volts up to kilo
electron volts that's a
remarkable tool because we can tune in
on particular parts of the spectrum and
work out what's going on the challenge
of this experiment is a really fun
experiment to do is we take
a silver surface which everybody's
busily preparing at the moment
and we're going to put our molecules
down onto that surface the first
challenge is how do we get the molecules
down into the surface well what we do
fortunately with c60 we can take it as a
powder
and that's how we we get we get about a
milligram of these molecules it's a
black powder we put it into an oven it's
literally an oven
and we bolt it onto the chamber we heat
it up and the molecules very nicely
sublime they go directly from the solid
phase to the gas phase and they stream
off as a beam of molecules they hit the
surface and they stick and if we do that
in just the right way
it's taking us a bit of time to work out
just what that right way is but if we do
it in just the right way then you can
get a nice ordered film an ordered
monolayer a single layer of molecules on
the surface then we take our beam of
photons they come in and we look at the
electrons that are given out by the
water we also interested actually in the
cage itself so we also look at the
electrons coming out from the carbon
that's the first stage of the experiment
but actually the technique we're using
here
in parallel
uh and a real advantage of this
particular beamline because it can do
this technique is something called x-ray
standing wave analysis and that's
that is a fascinating technique and
here's where my lack of a crystal comes
into play
what we do is we have a crystal there's
the surface of a crystal we have planes
of atoms
what we have here is our beam coming in
now if we tune our photon energy of our
beam
to something called the brag condition
right what that means is if we get the
wavelength of our beam so it's the right
is the same size as the spacing of the
crystals what will happen of the crystal
planes what will happen is that the beam
will get diffracted
so we have a beam coming in here and we
have a beam diffracted which comes back
out
and when those two beams interfere
what happens is we get something which
is called a standing wave it's pretty
well exactly what happens on a guitar
string you get a standing wave set up in
a guitar string in terms of the
interference of traveling waves on that
guitar string
and now the great thing is if we have
our molecule
at the surface we have this standing
wave field which has got a periodicity
it's a wave so it's got a periodicity
the molecule
bathed in this
wave that's the best way of thinking
about it you've got the molecule which
is sitting in this wave field and if you
change the energy of the incoming beam
just a little bit what you can do is you
can tune the maxima and minima you can
shift them back and forth
and by shifting them back and forth you
shift them back and forth through the
oxygen
and then what happens is if you look at
the electrons coming out from the oxygen
you will see a characteristic profile
depending on where the water molecule is
sitting with respect to the surface
planes the reason we're doing all of
this is to find out where in the cage
the molecule is sitting and moreover
we're not even restricted to those
planes what we can do is we can rotate
our sample and we can triangulate the
position after we can do the same thing
again and triangulate the position of a
single molecule within the cage we have
done some preliminary work we're fairly
confident it's going to be sitting
fairly close to the k to the center of
the cage which is relatively surprising
because when these molecules when the
fullerene molecules go down onto the
surface what happens is this charge
from the silver surface electrons go
into the molecule forms a quite strong
bond and yet the water just sits in the
middle of the cage well i don't care
what seam seemingly does it seems to be
completely screened from its environment
which in terms of actually being able to
exploit this effect to be able to uh
look at those
that water molecule exploiting the
device for example is um really quite
interesting we're locked in they're
going to turn the beam on we'll be fried
be absolutely fright
you're looking into the chamber
absolutely so you're looking into the
preparation one of the preparation
chambers this thing coming down with the
bellows is a manipulator that allows us
to move the sample up and down you've
got all these various what are called
feed throughs which allow you to feed
electrical signals in and out from the
sample for example to heat it for
example or to measure the temperature of
the sample the windows are obviously
obviously this is a wonderful invention
called a leak valve it allows you to
leak in very very small quantities of
gas
and that's what we need to do to prepare
our sample what we do is we bombard it
with organ ions business is happening
here in terms of the measurement is
happening
over here in these chambers over here
that's where the beam yeah in terms of
where the beam hits the sample and here
is going to our analyzer this this large
cylindrical tube this is our analyzer
thank you
thank you
for 10 weeks i think i guess yeah about
10 weeks since we did the beam time so
we've done some analysis and when i say
we i'm using the royal way i must admit
i've not been heavily involved with the
analysis it's been driven by